bonjour à tous
on est en mars 2014 2015 et vous avez
sans doute tous déjà entendu parler de
bitcoin revanche
connaissez-vous mort des arts organise
c'est quelqu'un d'assez connu dans la
communauté bitcoin je vais expliquer son
histoire porté à regagner et iraniens il
habite à ispahan à 500 km de téhéran et
depuis plusieurs générations
sa famille fabrique des chaussures et
les vents il possède d'ailleurs quatre
boutiques dans sa région et son commerce
marche bien depuis deux ans il a créé un
site web sur lequel vivent ces
chaussures
cependant vous savez que l'iran est
soumis à des sanctions internationales
et qu'aujourd'hui la plupart des moyens
de paiement internationaux justement ne
sont plus utilisables dans son pays
il a donc créé un site web il vend ses
chaussures en bitcoin grâce à ça il les
vend aux quatre coins du monde
directement alors combien ça coûte en
bitcoin une paire de chaussures chez
pearson chose ça coûte 0 866 bitcoin pas
d'intermédiaire pas de frais pas de
fraude
c'est là la recette ultime du commerce
je voudrais continuer mon propos avec
une réflexion très importante
vous avez tous entendu parler de bitcoin
comme étant une monnaie virtuelle
bannissez ces mots de votre esprit
bitcoin n'a rien de virtuel
ce bouclier ce fusil sont virtuels la
vache que vous allez acheter sur
facebook c'est virtuelle bitcoin n'est
pas virtuelle bitcoin est numérique est
très réel epic games c'est pas une
monnaie c'est une technologie un
protocole je vous expliquer ce que c'est
avec trois grandes notions
la première c'est ce billet vous avez
tous reconnu
est ce que vous savez le véritablement
de quoi il s'agit quelle est la valeur
de ce billet à quoi sert-il
et comment et créer l'argent alors ce
billet ne vaut rien la notion de valeur
intrinsèque d'ailleurs veut rien dire
toute valeur est relative la valeur
c'est l'expression de l'intérêt pour un
bien ou un service
donc en fait ce billet il vaut quelques
centimes le coût de sa fabrication
mais
il a une valeur d usage qui vous permet
d'acheter un bien ou un service d'une
valeur de 20 euros donc sa valeur est
fondée sur la confiance que vous avez
dans le système bancaire et dans les
états à vous garantir que demain vous
pourrez toujours acheter quelque chose
d'une valeur de 20 euros avec ce billet
pour preuve les vieux billets de 500
euros vous avez hérité de votre
grand-mère ne valent plus rien et
comment et créer l'argent c'est une
bonne question je sais pas si vous avez
la réponse la plus grande partie de
l'argent en circulation c'est la monnaie
scripturale c'est celle qui est sur le
compte en banque des uns et des 0 et le
plus possible si vous avez ça la monnaie
scripturale et créé par le crédit
comment ça se passe demain je vais à la
banque et je l'emprunté 1000 euros ne
pensez pas que les mille euros que la
banque va prêter sont issus des dépôts
vous avez réalisé à la banque
non la banque va faire un jeu d'écriture
elle va écrire au passif mille euros
c'est à dire les 1000 euros qu'elle va
me remettre l actif elle a aussi écrire
mille euros qui correspond à la tête ce
que je vais rembourser et l'argent a été
créé ainsi ses 1000 euros n'existait pas
avant
désormais il existe par le crédit que je
viens de faire auprès de la banque john
galbraith l'économiste disait le
processus par lequel les banques créent
de l'argent et si simple que l'esprit
résiste à y croire et effectivement la
plupart d'entre vous peut-être ne savais
pas que l'argent était créée ex nihilo
vous avez peut-être connu il s'agit d'un
louis d'or alors qu'est ce que c'est
alors c'est une matière première
rare il en existe 170 mille tonnes sur
terre ça représente à peu près un
immeuble de huit étages s'est pas
beaucoup et cécile confère sa valeur en
partie c'est qu'il est rare l'autre
partie de la valeur c'est qu'il a des
applications industrielles ou des bijoux
pendant très longtemps l'or a été une
monnaie des changes s'est changée de
l'or ont payé en or la monnaie valeur
cependant l'or a quelques problèmes
on peut facilement contrefaire de l'or
je veux prendre un lingot est inséré
deux barres de tungstène au milieu c'est
invisible et pourtant sert procès
ressemble à un lingot d'or s'est
difficilement transportable avec des
lingots d'or un peu partout et en plus
on peut pas diviser l'or comme on
voudrait arriver à la poussière on a du
mal à les changer
le prix de l'or n'est pas fixée par une
banque ou un état personne ne décide que
leur vaudra 35000 euros lingots
aujourd'hui ou demain
le prix de l'or est uniquement fondé sur
l'offre et la demande et il s'échange
sur des marchés partout dans le monde à
des prix différents d'ailleurs ça vous
connaissez également vous en avez tous
une dans la poche
c'est une carte bancaire alors qu'est ce
que c'est qu'une carte bancaire c'est à
la fois ce plastique dans la poche
c'est une marque très puissante derrière
et c'est aussi un réseau de transactions
mondiales
ce réseau a fait ses preuves marche très
bien
vous utilisez tous les jours et
globalement il ya très peu d'échecs
cependant ces réseaux ont été créés il
ya des dizaines d'années
ils n'ont pas été créés à l'époque
d'internet aujourd'hui la carte bancaire
n'est pas un outil de paiement adaptés à
internet
la meilleure preuve c'est la fraude qui
croît chaque jour et j'ai pris ce qui
représente aujourd'hui des dizaines
voire des centaines de milliards de
dollars par an
d'ailleurs ce réseau de transactions
mondiales pensez vous qu'il a de la
valeur qu'il est virtuel il est très
réel très concret et ils font de la
valeur des réseaux qu'ils supportent
derrière alors voilà bitcoin c'est un
peu un ensemble d 3 et pour être un peu
plus précis bitcoin ces trois choses la
première c'est ainsi que certains actifs
numériques rares ne seront émis que 21
millions bitcoin aujourd'hui il y en a
14 millions en circulation
c'est en même temps un réseau de
transactions peer-to-peer complètement
autonome sur lesquelles circulent le
bitcoin est en même temps
troisième chose c'est une base de
données décentralisée sur laquelle sont
enregistrées toutes les transactions
bitcoin de façon claire
public donc lisible par tous ce réseau a
plusieurs vertus non seulement il est
extrêmement résilient par son côté peer
to peer
il n'y a pas de point central que je
puisse couper ou arrêter et à qui me
permette d'arrêter le réseau et en plus
le fait qu'il soit distribué réduit
drastiquement tous les coups de
circulation des bitcoins dessus et quand
il a été créé inventé par satoshi
nakamoto vous avez peut-être déjà
entendu son nom
c'est un auteur pseudonyme on sait pas
trop qui se cache derrière c'est une
personne ou un groupe de personnes mais
il a écrit une spécification vous
trouvez sur le site people.com org huit
pages qui définissent bitcoin le
logiciel a été développé derrière libre
et la première transaction bitcoin a eu
lieu le 3 janvier 2009
alors comment ça marche bitcoin j'ai
représenté ici une adresse bitcoin est
avant de monter sur scène
j'ai été posées l'équivalent de 10 euros
l'adresse bitcoins cette chaîne de
caractères que vous voyez dans une
trentaine de caractère matérialiser dans
un qr code
cette adresse est publique tout le monde
peut voir sur cette adresse qu'il y a
bien quelques bitcoin correspondant à
ces fameux 10 euros ici j'ai représenté
une clé privée la clé privée c'est le
mot de passe qui va permettre de
dépenser les bitcoins qui sont sur la
clé publique sur la presse présentée
précédemment
ça signifie que la propriété de mai en
équivalent 10 euros elle est
matérialisée par cette clé privée
si je perds ça très privée je perds la
capacité à dépenser les pit lane
si je perds la clé privée je ne peux
plus prouver que je suis bien
propriétaire des dix huit des 10 euros
et donc comme vous avez compris le bien
que vous affichez ici la clé privée qui
va vous permettre de dépenser les 10
euros qui sont avant ces cadeaux le
premier kill l'écran c'est à lui alors
bitcoin aujourd'hui on l'assimilent
volontiers à ce qu'on était l'email la
voix sur ip et même internet vous
souvenez des années 90 peut-être pour
certains quand on disait que l'e-mail
venait d'arriver et vous entendiez la
pare brise interlocuteur mais t'es
gentil
je viens d'acheter un fax à 25000 francs
il fait 50 pages minutes tout le monde a
des facs c'est une tuerie pour ni mail
personnes en à personne n'attaque sais
je vois pas comment ça va marcher
on voit comment les choses ont évolué et
on voit d'ailleurs que les industriels
du fax ne sont pas devenus les champions
de l'économie numérique aujourd'hui
après la voix sur ip c'est un petit peu
le même principe
les opérateurs télécoms ont freiné des
quatre pieds des quatre fers pour qu'on
ne puisse pas utiliser la voix sur ip
sur les accès internet
et puis finalement c'est devenu la
technologie coeur de métier des
opérateurs télécom puisque rennes c'est
un peu la même chose c'est une
technologie libres qui vient s'appliquer
au monde bancaire et au monde des
transactions électroniques juste pour ce
point parce que c'est une technologie
libres à la mesure du mail ou la voix
sur ip et que ça s'applique au monde
bancaire
ça mérite de s'y intéresser un petit peu
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait avec bitcoin
je prends deux exemples le premier si
vous êtes tous retrouvés à vouloir lire
des articles sur mediapart les écoutent
ce que vous voulez et puis au bout de
trois lignes dire maintenant il faut
payer il faut s'abonner
mais moi je veux pas m'abonner je veux
juste bien l'article je faire la même
chose que dans la rue jeu sorti ma pièce
de deux euros la donne et prendront
prendre mon journal et mentale et en
aucune façon j'ai envie de m'inscrire de
donner mon numéro de carte bancaire et
ensuite d'être prélevé tous les mois et
compagnie je veux juste payé
instantanément mais c'est pas possible
car la structure de coûts des
transactions carte bancaire ne permet
pas de le faire
deuxième exemple si ici je vous demande
de m'envoyer 10 euros électroniquement
personne ne peut le faire
personne ne peut le faire parce que même
si on parle la même monnaie même si on a
les mêmes opérateurs télécoms tous les
systèmes sont privatif on est encore à
l'heure du minitel dans le domaine du
paiement
il n'ya pas d'interopérabilité epic
games vient apporter la brique
d'interopérabilité pour le paiement
électronique
alors évidemment le terrain de jeu sur
lequel on s'attaque c'est celui des
banques et des états ils sont assez
puissant et très rapidement ils ont eu
peur peur parce qu'ils n'ont pas compris
de bitcoin était une technologie libres
et cette peur elle a entraîné des
réactions assez violente que vous lisez
encore tous les jours puisque on vous
parle de petites communes de blanchiment
et le financement du terrorisme
je rappelle juste le 100% du blanchiment
passe par des banques superviser
aujourd'hui et que le meilleur moyen
pour faire du black
c'est le pied de banques utilisaient
surtout pas peak oil toutes les
transactions sont publiques et inscrits
indéfiniment et donc face à ça la
question qui se pose ne serait-elle pas
plutôt de savoir comment est-ce qu'il
faut appréhender les nouvelles
technologies l'exemple qui se pose de
nos jours c'est celui du drone vous avez
vu il fait l'actualité depuis quelques
quelques semaines le drone est une
innovation représentent ils une menace
c'est un vrai sujet et c'est la même
chose pour bitcoin bitcoin bitcoin c'est
une invention qu'on ne peut pas d
inventer et c'est une innovation qui est
porteuse davantage plus que de risque à
condition de l'adopter de la maîtrise et
de la comprendre
s'il a fallu simplement quarante deux
mille lignes de code pour complètement
bouleversé l'industrie bancaire
ça veut dire qu'on peut très bientôt
changer le monde et je vous invite à y
prendre part
en rejoignant ritaline merci